alors comment ça va ça va enfin venant
ça va pas j'ai vécu comme une sorte de
trauma de quoi trop marre du ont fait ok
sinon dit ok de pardon oui c'est quelque
chose à régler
qu'est ce que voulez bien vous avez
entendu ce que j'ai dis juste avant est
ce qu'on peut dire les choses
franchement oui pas vous vous est ce
qu'on peut se dire les choses
franchement oui toujours pas au rck
concentrez-vous un peu parce qu'on va
pas y aller je ne sais pas peur il vous
parle avouent d'ailleurs quasiment tout
le temps à vous donc à bon oui asie j'ai
peur de revivre le même trou mac rien de
drôle tardo d'accord pardon je l'écouté
c'est un tout petit peu compliqué
aujourd'hui mais on y va ok combien de
pénis 1 n'a comme forza fera plus sûres
ils vous regardent dans les yeux quand
ils vous pénètre non
très bien alors vous maintenant oui avec
le manteau bleu la chemise grise et moi
donc c'est toujours je sais mais je me
suis jamais vous chaque mois la raison